an argument at the cash register leads
to a deadly shooting at least that's the
word from a witness who watched a
shooting unfold inside of a local
convenience store it happened last night
around this time near mcleod and
tropicana victoria saha talked to one
woman who was inside one witness who was
inside at the time of the shooting tells
me it all started off of who was going
to pay next the doors at speedy market
near mccloud and tropicana are back open
wednesday after being closed for the
night because of the shooting one woman
who works next door does not want to be
identified because she says she no
longer feels safe how often would you go
into this
at least four times a week
now i don't feel safe going any longer
while near the store i came across a
woman who was inside the store at the
time of the shooting this witness is
still shaken up from yesterday she only
agreed to speak with me off camera she
tells me she was paying at the register
then a young woman was about to pay but
a man said he was next in line the
witness says the woman stepped back and
apologized that's when the man started
yelling slurs and threw a soda can at
her police didn't give us too many
details but say after the altercation
with the customer the woman left and
came back with a man who had a gun that
man allegedly shot the male customer and
ran off with no arrests made the
community is on edge i feel about it now
i can't even leave my house now except
for going to work the man who was shot
died at the hospital the witness tells
me he was homeless and would come to
speedy mart often police have not made
any arrests if you have any information
you were asked to call police reporting
near tropicana and mcleod victoria zaha
live local now